une rue fermée à la circulation des
terrasses ambiance musicale la rue de la
reine veut se donner des allures de
grande rue parce que c'est important de
créer des événements comme ceux qui vise
à rassembler la population qui a qu'une
vie interactive journée tout le monde
est heureux tout le monde est chaud rien
qu'on veut ce qu'on veut en fait c'est
voir comment la réponse publique vont
être par rapport au respect des
consignes qu'on commence à vraiment
doucement la rue est piétonne
il voit quelques animations surtout la
musique mais que du bout du monde on est
toujours intéressé par la musique les
consignes de santé publique sont partout
personne n'a l'intention de jouer à la
police
c'est la sphère de tout le monde selon
les organisateurs
on a mis toutes les installations en
place tout ça se fasse de façon
sécuritaire ya peut-être une trentaine
d' espaces qui peuvent recevoir bancs
tables à pique nique balançoire qui
prévoit recevoir des familles qui sont
tous à 2015 unes des autres
il ya du gel anti alcoolisées partout
sur le site des corridors de circulation
qui sont identifiés avaient de gaspé
veut valoriser les commerces de la rue
du centre-ville qui ont trouvé le temps
long
durant le confinement parlez-en à simon
poirier propriétaire de bistro bar
certain que le monde vont participer
on s'attend que le monde vont respecter
les consignes aux participants et c'est
quand même une fan de voir quelle équipe
du fmi bm ont décidé quand même de
d'avancer et de faire des activités pour
le monde de gaspé
[Musique]
la rue de la reine sera piétonne les
week-ends de 12h à 20h jusqu'au 9
ou ici bruno lelièvre du canada à gaspé